welcome to a whole new paradigm shift or
rather welcome to the very beginning of
a possibly exciting frightening paradigm
shift that's so new we're only going to
be beginning to figure out how to talk
about it here tonight with the three
experts we have are we about to head
into a brave new and frightening world
in which we may seriously consider suing
our grandparents or even our great
grandparents because they didn't take
care of their genome and we're having a
little trouble about it are we possibly
heading into a world in which we can
take a pill to change our feelings about
sexual orientation or about violence or
about war are we not already in a world
in which epigenomic effects described by
scientists are already the subject of
law cases there's a lot of legal
implications in what we're about to hear
but I've been warned by a number of
people including dr. James Watson
himself dr. Eric Kandel and some of the
older men and women who are Giants on
whose shoulders we stand to be very
cautious about what we talked about here
tonight because it's being overhyped
they say and yet I have yet to talk to
one scientist in epigenomics who begins
by saying we've got to be careful now
and within five minutes isn't ecstatic
nervously ecstatic about what this all
may pretend about what we will learn
about who we are what we are how
evolution really works in ways that turn
out not to contradict Darwin or Lamarck
and which may mean even that we may be
beginning to enter an era in which we
might ourselves now let's hope
cautiously take over the control of
evolution these are no longer ridiculous
questions that's the point of what we're
going to try to make a little sense of
out of out of tonight that when we talk
to our experts so first let me introduce
our three experts one by one our first
participant Randi turtle was nominated
as a PI magazine Person of the Year for
his pioneering work in epigenetics he
headed the epigenetics and imprinting
laboratory at Duke University until last
year now he's a visiting
McArdle laboratory for cancer research
at the University of Wisconsin welcome
Randy turtle
also joining us is Francis champagne an
associate professor in the Department of
Psychology at Columbia University she
researches the role of epigenetic
mechanisms when it comes to environments
and gene activity plants of champagne
and our final participant dr.
jean-pierre Issa is a professor of
medicine at Temple University and the
director of the cells Institute for
cancer research and molecular biology is
working on the large-scale mapping of
epigenomic patterns in normal cells in
aging cells and in cancer cells
jean-pierre Issa and now since we have
an enormous task ahead of us we thought
we'd start with the sixty second teaser
just to give you a sense of some of the
work that is nailing down these
possibilities I was just mentioning in
the 1980s when dr. Lars olla Begaren
investigated the records of a remote
Swedish village births and deaths feasts
and famines the data revealed something
strained experiences or habits of the
fathers appeared to be somehow
physically inherited by the sons and
grandsons and great-grandsons scientists
became detectives and opened up other
cases the data from the Dutch winter of
hunger and the Chinese famine in the
wake of the Great Leap Forward revealed
similar mystifying patterns what was
happening with jean-baptiste Lamarck
actually on to something when he said
that a giraffe that really stretches its
neck to reach even higher leaves would
give birth to a longer necked baby can
experience change our hardwired DNA and
our genetic destiny
that's the old paradigm that we were all
pretty well locked into up until about
ten years ago we have hardwired DNA it's
changed slowly by cosmic radiation
perhaps zapping it so every now and then
there's a little bit of variation but
now epigenetics is running through
conversations all over the planet
jean-pierre let me start with you for a
simple definition of epigenetics well
when people ask me about epigenetics
bill I just tell them look at me or look
at the mirror what do you see now what
you see if you look at me you see skin
you see eyes you see hair if Superman
was in the audience you would also see
liver and lungs and bones and all of
that and we have more than 200 different
tissues in our bodies they're very
different they don't look alike they're
very stable and here's the mystery we
have 200 tissues one DNA sequence so dr.
Watson who was speaking earlier today
when he discovered the structure of DNA
couldn't explain that how could you get
go from one DNA sequence to 200
different tissues at the same time in
the same person and so in the 1950s
Conrad Wellington a biologist was
studying this question and postulated
there must be something that works on
top of the DNA sequence and this is
where the term epigenetics comes from
epigenetics and at the time he didn't
know what it was but he said there must
be something that modulates the genes in
different tissues we now know what it is
and that's what we're going to be
talking about today
we now have an idea about what is do you
have it all 100% nailed down I wish we
did but we have some idea of the
mechanisms of how it is possible to have
200 tissues with a single DNA sequence
so epigenetics Francis a little bit more
on the word epigenetics what is epi mean
epi and top of above genetics obviously
the now we refer to that as the DNA so
these are all factors that come around
the DNA and ultimately affect how likely
it will be that the DNA is red or not
something like the old nature nurture
debate this being the nurturer of the
environmental part something
these epigenetics as we'll explore may
be affected by experience by trauma by
the environment exactly and when you
think of nurture
nature really what epigenetics
represents as the interface between
those two influences how our experiences
come to modulate what genes are turned
on and what genes are turned off we've
gotten the impression over the last ten
years at the old nature-nurture debate
60 40 40 60 70 30 30 70 is really a
hundred percent of each it's always both
and it's not even the right question
always both wrong question exactly thank
Randy hot field I think we may have a
graph that may point out what you're
about to tell us about the excitement
you all are experiencing who are at the
center of the discoveries you've been
making yeah it's a very hot field
there's a lot of people now working on
this field of research that weren't
working on it before a lot more
publications which you can see in this
graph for those of you that go into a
cold sweat when you see a graph this is
not very difficult this is number of
papers that is plotted against years
starting in 1990 and the important
points that you can take from this this
graph are really two if you look at it
and analyze it you can see that this is
an exponential curve it's grow the field
is growing exponentially and it's
doubling every two to three years by
plotting it this way and you focus on
that little asterisk that's where
there's an inflection point between in
effect if you were watching this from
above it would look initially from 1990
to about 2003 2004 that virtually
nothing was going on in this field of
research but after 2005 it's gone
vertical as they would say now in the
vernacular of the times it's gone viral
and this is what we're going to be
talking about today I mean frankly none
of us would probably be on this stage if
it wasn't for the fact that it has gone
viral and none of you would be probably
in this audience and just for a moment
to consider the implications as we'll
get into later of all of this what we
saw from the village of överkalix
passed down through generations
possibilities of trauma or famine
affecting what happens in people's
physical lives
three maybe even four or six generations
later children of PTSD in various
horrible things that have happened in
the past bearing these marks enormous
implications for law for society is it
not yeah enormous implications and one
of the most interesting implications is
that about ten years ago when they here
in genome was sequence some scientists
were saying well that's the end we're
gonna understand every disease we're
gonna understand every behavior and it
turns out we didn't because the sequence
of the DNA isn't enough to explain
behavior it isn't enough to explain
diseases and that's where I think the
field of epigenetics took off because
even hardcore geneticists started saying
wait a minute why are these people with
the same DNA behaving differently or
having different diseases and they
started paying attention to us on that
point people with the same DNA we all
heard of identical twins relatively
young ladies here but the same DNA at
the beginning and as they grew to be
older and older women differences
appeared what is this teaching us
Francis well when the first discovery
came to light that you know we have
these identical genomes but they start
diverging in terms of their character in
terms of what they're doing in in the
individual there was evidence that there
was an epigenetic divergence so when
you're young and you're twins you have
very similar epigenomes when you're
older and you're twins you have very
divergent epigenetic features and so the
implications was that as you walk
through life as you have your unique
experiences through that lifespan your
epigenetic changes are mirroring those
those experiences so be specific here
what you all have learned is that genes
can turn on and off and that they need
instructions they don't just sit there
and do what they do they need different
instructions and may get different
instructions to do different things at
different times in a person's life
exactly having DNA is great we need it
but we need to also know what and what
when genes need to be turned on and
turned off so does the light switch the
timing is incredibly important to
development and then functioning well to
anchor this in something physical let's
spend some 10 minutes here talking about
the mechanics of it at least what you
all know so far because I get the idea
you all feel you're just the beginning
of it
how epigenetics works we have a drawing
that we've put together here that I'll
ask each of you to help us explain and
it's a little bit unfinished on purpose
because the impression I get from you
all and your colleagues is that you're
just at the beginning of something very
exciting so let me first ask you Randy
over there on the right and this is
the double-helix of the basic backbone
of the DNA that we're all so familiar
with and that dr. James Watson was along
with Francis Crick discovered some years
ago but over on the right what is that
MD stand for me me me okay no it stands
for methyl group and a methyl group is a
carbon atom with three hydrogen's
attached to it that methyl group then
with proteins can be either put directly
onto the DNA or it can be added to the
spool that the DNA is wrapped around
which is comprised of histones and in
the process of doing this when those
methyl groups are put onto those two
regions one in the histones and one of
the DNA it will tend to cause that DNA
to condense and therefore it is inactive
and cannot be transcribed or make
proteins from from that gene whereas
over on the other side you have the AC
which is in a subtle group that can be
put on histones and when that occurs and
the methyl groups are removed the DNA
opens up they're still wrapped around
those spools but as a consequence now
factors can come in and cause that gene
to be transcribed and you get protein
the question before we get too deep into
the jargon there these things can be put
on it sounds like you're talking about
things that environment might cause to
happen or experience might cause to
happen that can that that definitely
does happen and and when they're put on
you can also put them on appropriately
in normal situation or the environment
can alter which marks are placed and you
can cause abnormal situation okay so
that's part of what the epigenome is now
jumpier but just to be clear that they
are put on for the most part based on
our DNA sequence and this is essentially
what happens in embryogenesis
they aren't or are they are they are now
so most of the programs is determined
however the program is not a hundred
percent accurate or efficient one is
right after fertilization in the embryo
the second is right after birth where
you have a lot of remodeling
particularly occurring in the brain
which is what Francis is going to talk
about and later on in life the wobbles
can occur because things don't work
quite as well which potentially can give
rise to cancer which was what dr. Issa
is going to be talking about primarily
right and while we're at
terminologies here what about histones
jean-pierre what are histones in which
DNA is located inside the cell there are
these round structures that you see on
this drawing around which DNA is wrapped
and histones are essentially the
gatekeepers for DNA they can either hug
the DNA and hide it away inside the cell
in a drawer so that the DNA is not
accessible that is not made into
proteins or they can open it up and say
here it is make RNA make proteins and
that's the central difference between
say a muscle cell and a liver cell in
that in a muscle cell there are histones
that are open up and say here make all
the genes you need make all the proteins
you need to become a muscle cell and in
the other cells these proteins are
hidden away in a compartment by these
histones so the histones are sort of
huggers and they can turn off a gene
that's right
the the methylations are tags that can
turn off ur on a gene is the case with
the histones so this is some of the some
of what you all have discovered about
the mechanics of the physical epigenome
and they maybe the point here is that
they may be affected whether they're
going to hug or not hug turn off or turn
on they may be affected by the
environment and things that happen to
the person exactly so we have a very
stable genome in blue ink but we have
these pencil drawings of epigenetic
changes around that blue ink and and
certainly you can take a methyl group
and you can add it to DNA you can take
that same methyl group off you can
change those histone proteins very
dynamically so even learning something
new will induce an epigenetic change so
these are very dynamic processes so you
all are learning how nature works and I
can see the humans in you and people
you're talking to say with nature can do
it we might be able to control it a
little bit and pencil up here is in
other words sort of like software then
and the blue pen drawing is what we've
all got is hardware and the software can
turn on and off I'm reminded to how
often when we have trouble and have to
call up the IT departments how often
it's mostly the software not the
hardware that goes wrong right much more
often and so you scientists have seen a
real potential to move in here at
something very exciting um triggered by
outside of it now there's one specific
question that I have here
this is what we all learn in middle
school is what gets passed down from
generation to generation the DNA part
the part in blue and it goes into the
eggs and sperm of the offspring and it
splits and the offspring get half of
their father's and a half from their
mother and that goes on down my question
looking at this is whether these these
first three best mobilization to settle
as a set elation and histones which are
also physically attached to the genome
do they also split and get passed down
through the germline to the moment of
conception did they become part or do
they get stripped off well the the
historic view was that they are stripped
off and they are to a large moment of
conception for the next at the at the
moment conception histone proteins for
the most part aren't in sperm these
there's a different protein in sperm and
when the two genomes come together to
create the offspring all of these
epigenetic changes are supposed to be
stripped away but I guess the the more
recent and exciting and kind of
mind-boggling finding of late is that
perhaps some of these changes aren't
stripped away and that they are carried
forward into the next generation so it's
not just the DNA pairs that go down into
the eggs and sperm of the next
generation that's right it's carrying
along methyl methylation baggage and
histone baggage right along into the
moment of conception yes that means
things that were affected by the
environment of person a in the child of
person area the first they may actually
go along they may I mean this is this is
the area of speculation that we have to
be cautious well we have to because you
have a lot of reason I see a smile on
your face ready to suspect it may well
be true well it's true at least in one
model system that we know which is the
goody Mouse system that we're going to
be talking about right but I've also
heard all of you another say that we
already know that this happens in plants
and insects is that true the epigenetics
get passed down without being stripped
off jean-pierre it is true epigenetics
plays actually an evolutionary law role
in plants in that there is some
epigenetic wobbliness or epigenetic
variability in plants such that when
plants are exposed to the environments a
severe drought
some of them will survive thanks to very
specific epigenetic changes that they
have in genes that allow them to survive
drought and then these plants will
transmit that information to their
progeny but it is wobbly after a few
generations it goes back to baseline so
this as opposed to the DNA sequence
which is fixed it's a DNA sequence is a
binary switch you're either on or off
epigenetics provides you more of a
variability and then that is an
evolutionary advantage for periods of
you know drought or here would it go off
if for example they were continually in
a stressed environment let's say for
example increased salt content or
something probably not right it'd be
selected for so it's only in if the
environment goes back to normal normal
where the drought disappears then it's
sort of gradually all those equations
goes back to four to five generations
probably gone well this term wobbley
which doesn't sound overly scientific
isn't reading I guess you're talking
about something that provides a further
variation of possible varieties that may
be there in the next generation to meet
whatever challenges come down the pike a
little just a little Bend for the reed
in the wind rather than having to break
exactly we wouldn't be here we wouldn't
be humans without variation evolution
requires variation in order to work we
have thought for many years that
evolution works only on genetic
variation but now we understand that it
can also work on epigenetic variation
the DNA sequence isn't everything that
matters for evolution and so the ability
to generate this variation is actually
important for evolution and we probably
are here thanks in part to this
variation and as wild and crazy humans
who seem so much more destructive and
productive in than any other creature
wouldn't be here without this as well
well that may well be the case that's
actually the work maybe of Francis but I
work you know more on cancer but yes
it's true and I certainly from my field
I could tell you that that is central to
many cancers and that cancer is
inevitable because of this variation
we'll get to that in a minute yes but
but just to make sure that we don't pass
up the implications already
you guys are finding mechanisms by which
events in a person's life like in the
överkalix
famine records we see maybe pass on to
grandchildren even to
great-grandchildren possibly a permanent
change in the genome so we have a kind
of responsibility for taking care of our
genome so that our great-grandchildren
won't sue us is that a possible question
well whether they can see or not it's
quite another question you're still
around but it's true I mean I there is
more and more evidence that grandparent
leaving great-grand parental
environmental exposures can impact you
and so these are these are big questions
and they're been fascinating studies by
the adult children of Holocaust
survivors by the adult children of
survivors of the Cultural Revolution the
adult children well in fact the children
who were in their mothers wombs at the
time of 9/11 having higher cortisol
levels the stress hormone which itself
can possibly as I understand from your
research leave scars on DNA as well and
so stress itself so first implication
here we may be responsible to try to
keep ourselves as relatively stress-free
in our own life as possible so that our
great-grandchildren won't be overly
stressed it either long after we're gone
you're laughing but that's because you
guys are opening up the possibility of
this being a sensible question all right
that is an essential point but keep in
mind that they are also periods of time
in our lives where we're more
susceptible to that and and it's really
the mothers when they are pregnant or
the fathers when they are conceiving and
so there there are periods of time where
we have to be much more careful about
our genome than perhaps other periods of
time so the more we learn about which
periods of time to be more careful right
the more knowledge and responsibilities
but potential also for good and
preventing suffering will come along so
let's look at three different
breakthrough studies before we get too
wild in our speculations here so we
really get a feeling for the hard work
that you all and your colleagues in the
scientific world have done let's start
with a study of mice and Randy I
understand these are known as agouti
mice is is this something from the high
Andes the agouti mice what does a GU
team eat and why why is this study that
you did now so often cited as being
important
understanding epigenomics well goodie
just means brown it's not not too
exciting so you have two mice I call
these the agouti sisters so from the hot
Dutch study in the Chinese famine
studies you knew that something
occurring very early in development and
literally in the first trimester of
development ultimately gave rise to
increase susceptibility to diseases
including cardiovascular disease obesity
diabetes in a doubling or tripling of
the incidence of schizophrenia so severe
lack of nutrition early and development
results in all of these disease
characteristics 20-30 years later the
real problem though was what is the
mechanism by which to glue the gravity
the molecular mechanism that holds these
two disparate time points together and
this is how this study why this study is
so important so the only difference
between the brown mouse and the yellow
mouse on this slide is what the mother
was exposed to when they were in utero
these are genetically identical mice the
mother on the left the yellow mouse that
mother was dis eating normal Mouse chow
the mother on the Left was eating mouse
child that was supplemented with things
like folic acid choline etc why those
compounds because they're the ones that
provide the methyl groups that we were
talking about before that are placed
down onto the DNA all those methyl
groups that are needed for programming
come in from our diet so that's why this
early time point is so important so here
you have a mouse that is small lean and
clean doesn't get diabetes doesn't
become obese the only reason is because
what had happened and what that mothers
that offsprings mother ate very early in
development and what we showed is in
this system anyway that that molecular
mechanism that relates these two time
points together is DNA methylation at a
region that's upstream is a GU T Mouse
so for the first time we showed that
small changes in nutrition can alter
disease susceptibility not through
alterations in the gene
but by alterations in the epigenome and
this is fundamental because it's
epigenomic it's definitely clear it's in
the parents of these mice the parents
were in utero when they had already been
conceived the mother was eating a
nutritionally supplement to diet the
brown animal for example was
supplemented and the one on the other on
the left-hand side the yellow animals
mother was receding normal diet so the
only difference is what the mother was
eating you gave the mother of the orange
one more vitamins less vitamins less
vitamins right and that meant that
certain preventive genes weren't turned
on or off weren't turned off the one on
the right had them turned off and you
and you traced the mechanism of it its
DNA methylation we know absolutely
that's the case in this model system so
and you have obesity the yellow animal
gets a higher incidence of cancer and
has a higher incidence of diabetes so by
supplementing the mothers diet early in
developmentally you prevent all of these
chronic disorders and one can already
imagine the potential for I believe
we're already in some locate courts
legal responsibilities of mothers or
legal responsibilities for employers in
the environment of fertile or pregnant
women or just fertile women it's
possible I don't get into the legal
aspects I have enough travel with the
scientific private right but the work
you all have done is now made this a
very sensible question exactly and
there's real potential for good from
this if we can understand how to protect
I like to think about and focus on the
good aspects of this rather than the
negative aspects right and and again the
question whether these changes could be
permanent going down through the
offspring of these mice and their
offspring in this model system if this
methylation change that we see upstream
of the agouti gene if this can be passed
on from generation to generation through
the mother through the father that is
not the case so this ability to have
transgenerational inheritance of
epigenetic effects appears to be
dependent upon the gene that you're
looking at it might even be dependent
upon how it's passed down through the
mother or the father that type of thing
these things have not been worked out
well even in this model system
in humans but it's beginning to be
nailed down its beginning peer-reviewed
journals so so here you have a video of
these little agouti mouse running around
again these are genetically identical
animals and I think you can clearly see
the yellow animals are massively
morbidly obese compared to the brown
ones and again that that difference is
completely determined by epigenetics not
genetics
now the question has to be raised here
these are lies but but these are mice
not humans these are mice you have good
reason though to believe that these may
be mechanisms that may be not totally
unlike our own it looks like from some
of the model genes that we've been
looking at for example these imprinted
genes which we might talk about later on
that that indeed is the case you can see
environmental alterations the epigenome
of these regulatory elements that
control the expression of these genes so
Francis and Jean Pierre when you learned
about what Randy had figured out here it
was of interest there's a great interest
and you know what's wonderful about this
model is its you can see it right we've
got a yellow obese Mouse and we've got a
brown Mouse and they are genetically
identical but clearly not the same for
epigenetic reasons that you can identify
exactly so I think it's it's really
strong evidence and it's just so
visually effective in explaining
epigenetics and I say it's not just
visual but but this really was one of
the first times that the irrelevance to
disease was very easy to show because
for many years we've been studying
epigenetics as a mechanism of
differentiation you know long versus
liver versus blood in here what you see
are mice that have exactly the same
genome yet have very different
phenotypes they look different and and
phenotypes are diseases diseases are
phenotypes so you can think in this case
of well they have a different coat color
but if you could see it you would also
see different susceptibility to cancer
as Randy mentioned diabetes obesity
potentially other diseases neurologic
diseases all of those linked to
differences in DNA methylation not
differences in DNA sequence so this was
a very strong indication to doctors out
there that epigenetics could be relevant
to disease
not just to differentiation so for every
every research area there is a model
system that's optimal and in for the
field of epigenetics this was the
optimal system for looking at this
initially breakthrough breakthrough
let's go to another breakthrough study
Francis moving up is or is it over from
mice to rats or doubt well we're not
going to get into that rodent politics
are we we don't need any more Francis
you worked with rat pups I believe we
have a picture of also the general field
of maternal care and various species
which is what's really important here
whether it be in humans or in primates
or monkeys or in these lovely little
rats in the upper right hand corner
we've all known intuitively down the
Aeons no doubt that maternal care can
make a big difference but you began to
zero in on it with your study with rats
and they're called rat pups the little
kids I think a little pop said what did
you what did you discover so you know we
were really interested in this question
of how maternal care could shape
offspring development something that we
intuitively understand our experiences
growing ups particularly with our
parents we'd have this this astonishing
effect on the way we function and so we
move that into the lab so that we could
really nail down the mechanism what is
it the mothers are doing to their
offspring to change their development
and we were particularly interested in
how they respond to stress the offspring
so how we respond to stress is really a
fundamental aspect of how we interact
with the world we might be more stress
we might be less stressed and certainly
in our pretty genetically identical
animals within the lab there are very
big differences in stress response with
some showing very high stress reactivity
and some is showing low and when we
looked at the amount of maternal care
those high and low stress animals were
receiving we realized that the
individuals that were that works were
very highly reactive to stressors we're
not getting as much maternal care from
their mothers during the very very early
stages of development and rats
unlike humans and primates spend a lot
of time licking their babies so it's
really all about the licking fur when
you're when you're a rat pup and so how
much licking you get from your mother
which is really you know a critical form
of tactile stimulation between mothers
and infants would predict all of these
long-term outcomes stress cognition and
a number of other another effects on
social behavior for example so finding
this we thought okay this is great we
can we now we know the mothers are
shaping these systems how are they
shaping them so if we look at gene
activity in the brain of adult animals
who had received high or low levels of
licking we found that the individuals
who had very low levels of licking when
they were infants when they were adults
certain genes that help you respond to
stress and and kind of recover from
stress were shut off epigenetically so
we looked at genes such as the
glucocorticoid receptor we found that if
you had high levels of maternal care
this gene was fairly active and
expressed and what that meant as those
animals could get stressed but they
could recover from the stress very
rapidly those individuals who did not
get very much looking grooming had very
low levels of these receptors because
they were epigenetically shut off with
DNA methylation so there's lots of debt
methyl groups attached to the to the
regulatory region of the the
glucocorticoid receptor gene shut that
gene off and these were going to be very
highly rece highly reactive to stressors
now when we looked at the female
offspring of mothers who engaged in high
or low levels of maternal care we saw
that the females inherited the the
variation maternal care that they
received so if they go if they got lots
of licking they also engage in a high
level of looking towards their offspring
and their offspring also engaged in high
levels of licking grooming towards their
offering so licking grooming this this
maternal behavior that is shaping
epigenetic profiles in the brain
affecting the way individuals respond to
stress was also being passed down
generations through the female line and
what we determined is that the more
licking and grooming you get during the
first week of life the more active
the genes are in your brain that
regulate maternal care itself so
maternal care tends to shut turn on
genes such as the estrogen receptor
which makes you more sensitive to the
hormones that females have during
pregnancy that prime you to be maternal
towards your offspring so I'm beginning
to hear something that sounds like it
may have an enormous amount of new
implications in what has been
controversial subjects in the past you
have what if I can borrow a term from
Bruno Bettelheim a cold mother doesn't
do much licking and a warm nurturing
mother does a lot and of course he was
famous for having postulated a long time
ago that cold mother syndrome led to
autism right now you're suggesting here
that cold mother syndrome in pet in rats
at least might also lead to serious
problems well low levels of maternal
care and and these are very stable
traits in these females has all of these
long term and perhaps even
transgenerational consequences but when
you look at why they're engaging in low
levels of licking grooming then you get
a very interesting answer so it's really
the environment writ large so I want to
be very careful about what I just said
because that idea by Brunel Deline yet a
lot of guilt to mothers of autistic kids
that has since been overridden and the
understanding is now it's far more
complex than that in autism may not be
anywhere near as simple as that
but this is just to give a sense to our
audience that what you all are opening
up again is a field of questions which
can have very controversial edges to
them and it's very powerful and there's
a whole field of medicine now that is
looking at fetal origin of adult disease
and so this is a complex a complex term
but it's a very simple idea it's the
idea that what happens in the womb and
what happens very early on in life might
influence your disease state or maybe
your psychology or maybe your rate of
depression 50 years later or 40 years
later and that's actually pretty amazing
from a medical terms because when a
patient comes and asks why did this
happen to me you know you go back a few
years and you start thinking did they
smoke what were their exposures you
don't think to ask what happened when
you were born or you know what did your
mother eat when you when she was
pregnant with you
yet that could be relevant to the
diseases that people get older
you know at later ages I want to take us
in a little bit of dangerous territory
here I'm thinking about the civil war
I'm thinking about the American Indians
and others who have suffered enormous
you were gonna I was just going to say
that the work that Francis has done is
actually as has really turned the field
I think of psychology on its head and I
have an interesting little tiny story
about this in Wisconsin there's a person
that I know and he said you know and
he's in a psychology building I said you
have a research lab in a psychology
building
he said yeah and he said you know what
they had to actually expand all the
sizes of the doors I said why is that
because he said I couldn't get in my lab
equipment
so research now in a psychology building
is now becoming wet lab research and the
reason for this is because of the work
that you and your colleagues have done
there's no doubt that it is who has been
changed forever
well this is what I was saying at the
beginning the beginning of a new
paradigm quite possibly although all
kinds of experts are very nervously
ecstatic about it but to introduce one
of the reasons why what you're just
suggesting here is that there may be it
may be the trauma if we could take a low
looking and expand the idea leave scars
on the DNA one way or the other you're
nodding yeah exactly and you know going
beyond just looking grooming there's
animal models of abuse and and certainly
in primates there's evidence that abuse
leaves this lasting epigenetic change
even in the human brain Wow now at that
point let me just expand a little bit to
something else war horrible genocides
have been visited in all kinds of groups
of people they've been discovered in
primates by Jane Goodall and other
scientists they seem to be something
that cruelty seems to be selected for in
evolution as Edward o Wilson has once
said the thing about us humans is were
just so damn dominant damned dominant
because sometimes we're dominant by one
grouping more cruel than another and
hurting another group this leads if I am
NOT going too far to the possibility
that cruelty may also be selected for
because it can make a group more
dominant because by causing trauma to
another group it diminishes the powers
of that other group for a while they
have more Carter soul is that a
reasonable question now
no questions unreasonable but what I
think certain I mean you could have all
of these factors that are contributing
to higher levels of aggression in an
individual and there's certainly that
could have an epigenetic basis but at
some point you have to give way to
intergroup relationships so it's not
enough just to be aggressive to everyone
around you if you want to live and
survive and prosper you have to get on
with your own group well the idea lately
is that there's within groups altruism
is selected for so that your group can
be strong but between groups right the
group that can be most cruel to the next
group is going to be dominant but I
think the point is that there's no
selection for one thing there's no
selection for cruelty there is selection
for variability because if you take a
group under some circumstances there
might be war and under those
circumstances groups that have more
aggressive traits might survive but
there might be other circumstances where
there is no reason for war it is those
groups that for example are more
intellectually inclined who can discover
agriculture or can discover ways to grow
food that are going to be selected for
so ultimately evolution doesn't like one
thing it likes to have a diversity of
things in a given group so that under
the right conditions that group would
survive no matter what and that's where
epigenetics also provides this
flexibility so you can imagine where you
have an extended family where you know a
couple of the uncles are very aggressive
and a couple of the aunts are very nice
the nurturing and that that the group
will survive no matter what the
environment is and then that's what
matters I think to evolution and note of
caution against myself in all of us here
I just made some leaps there but the
implications of what you're finding
about what passes on and weakens later
generations from lack of caring may have
implications for how one group of humans
is kind or not to another group of
humans which points us towards thinking
about our desire for a peaceful world in
which all the groups have to try and try
to not traumatize each other too much
yeah if trauma has these
intergenerational effects and certainly
the evidence suggests that it does and
then I think we get back to this wobble
so we we may need this aggression or
hostility to our other groups to last a
few generations but we may not want it
to last forever within our genes and so
that's where the wobble this
unscientific wobble may be very handy to
get rid of these effects after they've
been I'm afraid this gets back to the
whole thing about the genome being
really quite static but the epigenome
being plastic and that's the advantage
of having these two systems you've got
something that's where are less rigid
and can be passed forward from
generation to generation without much
change and then you've got this plastic
situation they can respond rapidly to
the environment and that gives rise to
these wobbles you know as we were
talking about the wobbles and that can
either be selected for or against for in
a short-term or if the the environment
stays this way potentially in a
long-term and it will be fixed at that
point and what's getting exciting about
what you all are saying here is that we
humans in this auditorium and you guys
who are doing the hard work now
understand this so we may have the
potential understand the mechanisms by
which it happens right we don't know
right now the genes that are involved in
this particularly in humans and and the
regulatory elements that are involved in
these processes what we need to know now
but what we're learners they're opening
the possibility that we may be able as
one movie director who had a lot of
movies that showed the bad side of human
nature and he was a interviewer
complained about this and he said yes
but it shows we can get our mind around
it you're showing us we can get our mind
around this bad side of human nation so
we may be able to choose to be kinder so
that we don't perpetuate the cycle of
violence down to the generation so bill
we're scientists the important thing
today is to go beyond speculation and
the real nice advances are that we can
measure these things really what has
made the difference in the past 15 20
years is not the understanding of
epigenetics since it was postulated in
the 1950s but now we can see it we can
measure it in the lab these tags that
you talked about these bookmarks you
know the methylation the acetylation you
know we could actually take
or genome or take somebody you know in
this room's genome and study the
methylation States and look at all the
gene and ask how much methylation is
there in this gene and this is that
correlate with say agressivity does that
correlate with having there be this and
so we are asking questions and these
questions need to be answered with data
we're all here interested in actually
doing these studies rather than simply
speculating about this but we're excited
because the implications are enormous
right well now let's go to a third
breakthrough with some of your work John
Pierre you have taken this to come back
down to earth to an actual work in
cancer right and you've had some
remarkable successes with it
right what you see here on the left is a
cat scan of a patient with lung cancer
where that cancer is seen in that circle
here it's it's the the opaque tissue in
there shown in white and what the group
discovered about 20 years ago now is
that when you compare cancer to normal
tissue from the same tissue there are a
whole lot of epigenetic changes you know
all these tags are disrupted a lot of
the histones are disrupted there are
really wholesale changes in the
epigenome and it took many years for
people to believe it and it took even
more years for people to start taking it
seriously but we now know in models of
cancer that we can actually cause cancer
by reconfiguring these tags I like to
tell people that these are like
bookmarks and if we simply reconfigure
the bookmarks then there's a different
instruction program and we can see that
in cancers there's a very different
instruction program when we study DNA
methylation and histone modifications so
a few years ago a group of us said well
can we reverse that is there any way to
put the bookmarks back to where they
could be and there were drugs that had
been discovered many years before that
were simply tools sitting in the
laboratory to study and we ask if we
give these drugs to people will it help
restore the epigenetic programs and and
and what we are trying to do in people
is epigenetic reprogramming the same
thing that happens
embryos and so this patient who has lung
cancer was treated with one of these
drugs in what she sees after a couple
months that big circle showing the
cancer the cancer shrank and after about
six months the cancer actually went away
astonishing and we have hundreds of
patients now where we see this
phenomenon where simply reshuffling the
epigenome results in remarkable
responses in some of these last four
years and so you've had treating for
example catchers like MDS blood and bone
marrow fill the first disease where this
particular treatment was tried were
forms of leukemias and now there are
four drugs that work on the epigenome
that are fda-approved worldwide there's
more than 100,000 people who have
received drugs in this form and many of
them have been helped they prolong life
they work better than chemotherapy in
these diseases and there's a whole field
of epigenetic therapy that has resulted
from these studies and virtually every
large drug company now is trying to
develop drugs that target the epigenome
to do just that reprogram genes and see
whether that will help cure cancer so if
I understand correctly from what you've
said before you're basically telling the
you're not going out to kill the cancer
cells you're going out to just get on
different directions to tell to be human
again
exactly so I've described this as as
this is different from the war on cancer
this is diplomacy in cancer right
we're trying to do with these drugs is
we're trying to change the instruction
program of these cells to remind the
cells that they should behave you know
stop growing you know stop being poorly
behaved cells at a genetic edge yeah
exactly I mean many of us who are
parents would like to do that to our
teenagers from here we're trying to
remind these cells that they are not
that they shouldn't behave that way and
in some cases what we see is that the
cancer doesn't go away but it stops
growing
you know the cells have normalized this
essentially in some cases they start
functioning normally they start making
the proteins that there should be doing
and we've really reversed the cancer
program back to a normal program I think
Randy we were talking about this before
you said that actually once you tell
these cancer cells to stop goofing
around and be human again they actually
die in the process
yeah it's through a process of apoptosis
apoptosis eight nine hours em tomorrow
apoptosis is a new word it means
programmed cell death and in effect what
they're doing is committing suicide and
so they cannot behave normally
but now the programs have been reset as
dr. Issa said and it drives other cells
basically if you can't be normal you
must die and that's what happens they
slowly the tumor disappears the
implications are already evident in the
giggles in the audience
normally you must die vacations are
humans I mean you're not only in cancer
they're potentially also important in
for example treating or preventing
neurological disorders I mean there are
many places where the field of
epigenetics is going to impinge upon our
biology neurological disorders Francis
talked to us about the risks and the
potential for using epigenetic
directions to treat neurological
jurassica that gets to mental health it
gets to all kinds of things in the brain
you've been working on some of this yeah
I have some warnings here I believe well
you know we've taken you know for
example our rats they're getting high in
low levels of licking grooming you take
them as adults and if we put a drug in
the brain that can reprogram these
epigenetic marks we can erase the the
kind of the effects of their early life
maternal care
so we can improve the functioning of
those individuals that did get low
levels of care but I think the other way
around the other way around so if we
give them a lots of methyl Matheny we
can increase those methyl groups and
make them more stressed but I think the
key and all these experiments is we're
putting it right in the brain if you're
psychotic and I give you a drug that
blocks your dopamine receptors that
might reduce your psychosis but it'll
also cause a lot of side effects right
so it'll affect you it the way you move
think of what these epigenetic drugs
could do on a whole genome-wide scale
across the body if we gave the drugs the
same way that we give antipsychotics it
could possibly reprogram every cell in
the body and that's probably something
we should be a little bit cautious about
it reminds me of some of the
geoengineering that is being talked
about for manmade global warming that
people want to do and say well yes you
can put sulfur in the air and make cool
things but it'll do many other things
too the complex system of the planet
that we don't understand so there's an
enormous amount of caution again
something we have to continually
remember during this session here I
think we have to be very careful I'm
going to ask you dr. Issa about this I
mean you're treating patients with these
types of compounds are you finding
problems with neurological disorders and
the people that are being treated for
cancer right so we're not but but keep
in mind or now that that we are not but
keep in mind that the brain does not
turn over therefore the brain often does
not actually see these drugs the only
cells that are seeing these drugs are
the cells that are turning over and
cancers turn over more than other cells
and that's why we are seeing specific
effects of these drugs on cancer cells
rather than normal cells but I mean that
discussion is extremely relevant and
important we're only beginning to
scratch the surface of how to do this
what is important about this patient and
about the field in general is a proof of
principle we have shown that the
epigenome is that normal in cancer we've
had to convince many geneticists who
thought cancer is all genetics and it
can't be epigenetic now everybody
understands that it probably is as much
if not more epigenetic than genetic and
we've had to convince doctors that we
could actually develop therapies based
on this and well we have proof of
principle many patients alive today but
you know who wouldn't be alive today but
for these drugs ten years from now we'll
know a lot more about how to use them
when to use them at what doses will have
many other dopes will have many other
drugs and maybe we'll be able to find a
way to change the epigenome only of
nerve cells and not of other cells or
the epigenome only of breast cells in
patients who are at risk for breast
cancer we don't know how to do that now
but you know the the field is advancing
so rapidly that it is not impossible to
think that 10 years from now we could be
doing that if I could alter the tone a
bit and bring it down just a bit
financial considerations surely pressure
what you all are able to do and whenever
we've been covering science stories
before and we see real breakthroughs we
usually see groups who had financial
stake in the earlier forms of cures that
may now be found to be not the right
form of cures are you finding any kind
of denial from from dealing with with
with your work in medicine from groups
who were making money from the old kind
of medicines that you're now trying to
replace well I don't believe in
conspiracy theories about you know
people who are blocking research I don't
think this is the case in in in medical
research and in our fields but it is
true that the hardest thing to fund are
the new ideas particularly when that's
where the National Institutes of Health
is so important because if if you rely
only on say drug companies to fund
research companies fund what is safe
they found what they know if someone
comes up with a brand new idea like wait
a minute
cancer is epigenetic not genetic and I
want to develop drugs for that companies
20 years ago would say you're completely
nuts why would we put our money into
that right so the considerations here
isn't really active resistance but you
know issues of where the innovation
comes from and the innovation is what is
hardest to fund yeah I mean I'm gonna go
back to the fetal origins of adult
disease susceptibility which is what we
started out with back when that proposed
the epidemiological data were supporting
this very strongly many many people many
people did not believe this because
scientists you would think that this
wouldn't happen but it does when there
there's no known mechanism for something
to happen they make the assumption it's
the same thing as no mechanism but
there's one word different which is
known and that's why our study that we
originally had with the agouti mice was
so important because we now know the
mechanism by which this occurs at least
in animals so it gives credibility to
all of these fields of epigenetic
research and one of the reasons why that
curve that you initially saw when
vertical after around 2004 is basically
what it meant then is it brought in all
of these groups in medicine under the
big umbrella of epigenetic research
because they lot of people realized that
indeed their research also needed to
take into account epigenetic phenomena
up until that point and even to a
certain degree even now people and
scientists are looking at biology
through that I call genomic lenses or
genomic glasses I'm old and I have
bifocals in fact I even have trifocals
we need to look at biology through both
genomic and epigenetic lenses or glasses
in order to truly understand how these
diseases are formed how to prevent them
and how to treat them so I'm hearing the
sounds of a new paradigm down more and
more Francis have you run into any kind
of denial as this brand new insight and
way of seeing things has come along well
you know we had a lot of trouble
convincing people that maternal care
could alter epigenetic changes the the
most severe resistance I've ever seen
in in science and I think you know a lot
of it's just it's new and it and at the
time it was going against an existing
dogma in science and dogmas and science
are can be useful they give some
guidance some rules to the way things
work but they can also be very dangerous
because they restrict the kind of
questions we can ask and and that's what
we ran against because there was this
idea that modifications like DNA
methylation once they're in there and
they can only be modified during
the embryonic development they're there
and they can't be modified so the fact
that mothers could come along and modify
these the epigenome was something that
was just a little bit too new at the
time now or Windows is fine in reading
in reading some of the research about
your work I came across this phrase
cryptic maternal effect a powerful
phrase yes but what are cryptic maternal
effects well you know in this discussion
of how traits are passed across
generations there's a large interest in
these germline effects that epigenetic
factors are becoming incorporated into
the germ cells and being inherited much
like DNA but there are a number of ways
in which traits can be passed across
generations equally involving epigenetic
changes but in a very different way and
so we're looking at how mothers can
shape generation after generation of
offspring not necessarily through
changing the germline but by changing
the brain so not necess
by changing the brain yes so the way if
I change your brain that changes the way
you behave if I change the way you
behave to your children it can change
the way they develop it'll change the
way they interact with their children
and this is sort of oh yeah of course
we've always known that but the point is
you guys are figuring out exactly how
nessam it's all about mechanism eken ism
so it may be down from the DNA into the
next German egg and down sperm and egg
in the next part meaning or it may be
its froggy leap frogging in the moment
of conception but still passing from
generation to generation all right so
now let's in our remaining 20 minutes or
so let's begin to open up some of the
windows and take some risks and seeing
what some of the implications of this
extraordinarily exciting work you're
doing Ahrens and what other parts of
society it may affect Randy just before
they started we were chatting about the
Civil War and epigenetics now remember
this is a bit BSE no but but just to
give you all a sense of the new kinds of
exciting conversations that are now that
now having at least the appearance of
responsible conversation
right give it I made when we were
sitting down I made the comment that in
the south we it is the what would you
call at the stroke belt the obesity belt
the cardiovascular belt etc and given
what we know now about epigenetics and
the fetal origins of adult disease
susceptibility being potentially at
least in potential in humans been an
animal model surely involving epigenetic
changes that when you have severe lack
of food you can start setting up these
types of situations that might be passed
on from generation to generation so one
of the places in the South where you had
tremendously a lack of food was during
the Civil War so it's possible that
these diseases that we're seeing these
chronic diseases might be increase in
incidence it might be a legacy of the
Civil War itself how that would be
actually be studied I don't know but I
think it would be a fascinating study
right here in our own country to look at
that if it would be possible through
records to be able to look at that in a
reasonable way and I don't know how that
would be done right and to be very clear
you're not saying this is the case but I
don't know a reasonable question given
what you've worked on and what they
found it's an interesting postulate fair
enough other aspects of the new
wide-open windows of legal
responsibility that we may have here
let's talk a little bit more about PTSD
the liability that we now understand
PTSD has because that has implications
for for the legality of war and for the
inheritance from war and all of the
genocide 'el and other regular horrors
that go along with war you're nodding
again yeah no I we've been working with
the Department of Defense to look at
questions like this and how particularly
how PTSD can affect parental
relationships with children and how this
might become inherited across
generations so trauma is likely going to
be something that it has an
intergenerational impact and so we have
to think about this one we're exposing
individuals voluntarily to trauma and
again our understanding coming back to
some of
the horrors of war being that they they
leave the other population diminished in
its ability to handle stress exactly and
and you know this is something that's
going to affect the way they interact in
an environment that's non stressful I
think that's but one of the big issues
with PTSD is that you're being exposed
to a trauma that's just an
uncharacteristic of a typical
environment so how are you expected to
function within a normal environment and
and and this again leads to the question
of intergenerational equity and the joke
I was sort of making are we looking
towards a future in which it may not be
unreasonable to think of suing your
parents or grandparents or your
great-grandparents because they didn't
take care of the genome that you are
right or you could see the government
for creating an environment to sue
governments as we found out but again
you're again pointing us towards a new
new sensibility among humans of what we
are and what our governments are really
responsible for again this idea that we
are each responsible for taking care of
our own genome not becoming alcoholic if
we think we have a tendency towards
because of what it might do by the way
what about alcoholism does that leave
scars on DNA it leaves an epigenetic
trace it leaves it in the brain of the
individuals who drink it leaves a trace
in the sperm of the individuals who are
exposed to alcohol and their offspring
so very likely and you think of the
large-scale amount of alcohol that we
can see especially when we're younger
that this might affect reproduction you
know decades you know that alcohol was
actually tested in the agouti mouse
model 10% alcohol continuously in the
maternal diet and what it caused
surprisingly it was a positive adaptive
response
wait a minute wait a minute just talking
about mice
but we know drunk mice but we know for
example that low levels drinking alcohol
for example one to two glasses of wine a
day for example help our cardiovascular
system but I always make the point that
one or two glasses a day might be
advantageous in other words positively
adaptive but I can get almost guarantee
that a gallon a day is not going to be
positively the point here is that a lot
of these epigenetic changes in how the
environment affects that is dose
responsive so at low doses you have no
effect then you get an optimal effect
and ultimately you get a negative effect
and mostly the epigenetic effects in
studies that have been done have been
done at a single dose so you don't see
this u-shaped curve and I think a lot of
the environmental insults that were
exposed to in fact with us with low
doses of ionizing radiation it's again
positively adaptive up until you get up
to higher and then it's negative so this
is not an on/off switch
it's a rheostat and it depends on where
you are in that dose response curve as
to what the effect is going to be and I
want to make a comment about how much we
don't know in this field particularly
about interventions that are dietary or
alcohol or things like that and and
sometimes what we think we know turns
out to be completely wrong for example
if you look at Brandis mouse model
giving the mothers extra folate looks
like it's beneficial because it results
in more of these little thin brown mice
that have less cancer but randomized
studies in people suggest that if you
give folate to older people it may in
some cases increase rates of cancer it
may increase mortality and a lot of
people are taking folate in their
vitamin which in my opinion they
shouldn't be so the point is that here's
one situation where folate is good
another situation where folate is bad
ultimately we we just don't know a lot
about what really we should do to
maintain an optimal epigenome and I want
to make sure people don't run into a
pharmacy and start taking pills left I
drank in the gallon of wine a day
thinking you will normalize the
epigenome I wish I knew what what we
should do well in fact you're reminding
me of what you might call fashions in
the advertising noise right for example
lately we've been hearing antioxidant
antioxidant have de Occidente but I'm
hearing a few things lately from some of
you and some of your colleagues that may
be antioxidants are go away so great
correct there's some evidence that in
some cases they actually increase the
risk of cancer and although we showed
with this a good email system where rate
low doses of radiation were positively
adapted was completely negated by
antioxidants so that's a negative effect
of antioxidants thank you that's very
interesting stuff
no no they did all and the whole point
being here that you now are showing
evidence that you can begin to figure
out about exactly now to open up some of
the other wide windows here of where
this is going because I'm beginning to
get overtones of a dreaded word from the
early 1900's that made their way all the
way into Nazi Germany eugenics meaning
well born the eugenics movement that
sterilized inferior humans was finally
stamped out in America but made its way
into Hitler's Germany too for horrendous
unspeakable results and I'm hearing here
again the possibility of this
double-edged sword of human knowledge
like nuclear power when it came along
good and bad there's a new potential
here for knowledge about eugenics is
there not that could be very frightening
if am I wrong and in having this concern
well I think you know dr. Issa mentioned
variability and the power of variability
and how important it is for us to be
different right we don't want to so we
don't know what what's optimal we might
think well if something is optimal now
but it might not be optimal ten years
from now and so I think that's always
the fear when we start selecting for
traits based on genetic or even
epigenetic factors that yes will do fine
in the short term but in the long room
and long term and certainly into
generationally this might not be a very
good move well I mean even even Francis
with your rats I mean those normal rats
like the liquor and groomers and the
paws off rats right those those animals
were all part of the same variability of
the population so
not something that's good or bad I mean
if something dramatic is happening you
want an animal that's a little stressed
because they're probably going to escape
whereas the other ones probably aren't
going to escape so it just depends on
the environment and the way the species
survives is and again as you're saying
is to have this in this variability
within the group a very basic important
point here is that for survivability
it's good for the group if it's going to
survive to have a variety of
psychological types and it's been
pointed out that Winston Churchill was
chronically depressed like his father
and grandfather but it was a lucky thing
at the time because chronically
depressed people are organized by an
external invited them in the Battle of
Britain against the bombs so they're
this wobbly mr. you're talking about
this variability is what's good if
you're if you watch it carefully and
it's not too wobbly well well you know
it's if it's too wobbly it might have
both good and bad effects I you know it
is entirely possible that the same
mechanisms that lead to say autism might
also lead to Einstein I mean it might
also lead to individuals who have
extreme intelligence and therefore make
great advances forward in the society
and if we stamp down those mechanisms
and we say okay we're gonna make sure
that there's no variability and there's
no you know no risk of having these
neurologic disorders then we also step
out you know the emergence of the most
creative people which I'm sure if you
looked at their epigenetics they would
be different from the norm and so from
you know on paper you would say we also
should stamp these down because they are
you know they're not part of the norm so
diversity is what makes us evolve as a
species and diversity is what makes a
society very successful in general and
so it's very important to be careful
here not to you know throw out the baby
with the bathwater in that case and we
want some degree of wobbling and and to
be cautious about putting negative
connotations on various labels such as
autism
it's differently enabled and some
Asperger's is said to be a kind of
autism
there's some great Asperger II
scientists and other people some of
brought us great things definitely
[Laughter]
scientists always get a nice giggle
going when I talk about it because you
all recognize something there right we
all know people with that in it who are
brilliant really absolutely brilliant of
course of course and that you know comes
to around this diversity right and so
there's really humans are very diverse
in their psychological makeup in their
brain makeup in their abilities and in
some cases these abilities people who
look off in society might be those who
are gonna save this society by
discovering the next vaccine or you know
the the next computer or some and you
all now understand epigenetics to be a
major part and what causes this
variability exactly and that's what's so
exciting here and it leads towards we're
getting towards the subject here of
intelligence itself which I was having a
conversation with both James Watson and
Eric can tell to do a Nobel Prize
winners just before this and they were
both talking about how intelligence is
no simple G factor general but there's
it's a wildly diverse concept which has
many different ways of being expressed
there's many kinds of intelligence and a
myriad of mixtures of them so again this
epigenetic variation sounds like it's
more and more valuable for us to
understand right I've also heard of said
the supercomputer has not been invented
yet they can even dream of beginning to
map the epigenome the way we have the
genome we you think the genome is
complex think of all the different DNA
methylation patterns you could possibly
all those histones which can undergo
many many different modifications that
vent various flights and those are just
two of many possible epigenetic ways of
modulating so to be clear about this
these are just the first two or three
with the acetylene you all have
discovered and there may be dozens and
dozens and dozens there are already
known and they work in combinations
studying one may not be enough to
understand links and then studying ten
and then looking at how these
combinations function is extremely
difficult right I mean what we're doing
in the field of epigenetics I think is
that again coming from my computer
science background and engineering
backgrounds we're line by line too
the programs of life that's what we're
trying to do say that again line by line
decoding the programs of life and that's
what we're trying to do right now it is
immense
thing to do it MIT's
well we're getting the end and what I
was saying at the beginning jokingly but
wondering are we beginning to look at a
possible future where there may be pills
that no gonna no doubt be prescription
pills that you could take to change your
feelings of sexual orientation or your
feelings of this kind of intelligence or
that kind of intelligence or your that
that's not impossible now so this is not
impossible but I just keep in mind that
our brains are mostly developed when we
are in the womb and very early in
infancy and therefore the idea that you
know a grown person is going to easily
change their epigenome to change their
psychological makeup I think it may
simply not be possible it may be
possible to influence the process in the
womb and very early on but there's a
window where this might be possible but
past that window that's gonna be
difficult however I do want to talk
about something we haven't talked much
about is that this wobbliness we keep
talking about that there's some
uncertainty into where these methyl
groups exactly are and how much they are
this is important for evolution it's
important for societies but it has a
detrimental aspect and so this is the
one thing that I alluded to but I will
make sure I keep people in mind is that
this wobbliness exists within us and it
turns out that it changes as we age and
and that is might be one of the
important societal things that we have
to keep in mind in epigenetics is that
when we look at 70 year olds or eight
year olds their epigenome actually has
significantly drifted from when they
were 20 or 10 and that that wobbly Ness
and that drift may be one of the
contributing factors to many things that
happen as we age you know including
cancer but also perhaps neuro
degeneration perhaps heart disease other
things and that's the one thing where we
have to be
we have to understand why our epigenome
changes with age how can we prevent
these changes so you're saying that this
may be able to lessen the effects of
senility that's well maybe maybe and
maybe lessen lessen the chances of
developing cancer lessen the chances of
developing it also means for example
lacing your flour with folic acid which
is going to be it's been shown to be
advantageous from reducing neural tube
defects that later on in life
particularly and when you're much older
could lead literally to an increased
incidence of cancer so what's good for
one age group might not be good for the
other age group and that's where taking
care of our epigenome and taking
responsibility for our epigenome might
actually lead to longer healthier lives
and maybe someday we'll find a pill that
we can give to it that doesn't change
your sexual orientation but it does
significantly change your risk of
developing cancer or your risk of
developing Alzheimer's disease or
something like that genes are not
strictly our destiny and there might be
ways to change that to some degree and
to change the way we age you're nodding
yeah that's what I think that's
absolutely correct the possibility that
we may now understand evolution itself
and be able to take over control of
evolution tell us what an imprinted gene
is in about 30 seconds well the to me
one of the most important things that
has to be done and this is from my
perspective now everybody here would
have a different perspective is that we
have to define those genes in our genome
that are just called genomically
imprinted genes and there are genes that
are expressed only from one copy with
one copy that silence the silence
epigenetically the importance of this is
that when you only have one functional
copy it's like you have a computer but
you haven't made a back of a of it so as
a consequence in this case a single
genetic event or a single epigenetic
invent can completely just regulate the
expression of the gene these genes are
developmental genes that are involved in
growth regulation and they vary greatly
between species and it the information
we have thus far from an evolutionary
standpoint that this evolved about 200
million
years ago and we still have these genes
that are imprinted but they vary greatly
between species suggesting that once the
phenomena the epigenetic phenomena of
the mother and father turning off
different genes so you only have one
functional copy evolved that that
software type approach was literally
used to specie 8 so evolution discovered
an even more a faster way that involves
mutations and epigenetic events at the
same time it's almost the mosaic so
we're running out of time but that means
that it looks like there's evidence that
evolution itself discovered an even
better way to spend us our very faster
faster evolution and now the downside of
this though is once you use software to
evolve you now become more susceptible
potentially to diseases ah and
neurological disorders cancer etc
because these epigenetic events that are
acquired to silence the gene can be
altered by evolutionary rights pleasures
so and now we might be able to add a
third stage of speeding it up because we
have the knowledge to possibly help
evolution itself well I want to get one
question in here from the audience I see
a hand up going right there yes ma'am no
speeches please keep it short and quick
something we need to know
the question had to do whether this
therapy could reverse the metastasis
process and the answer is yes in those
patients who are benefiting from this
it's not just the primary cancer that's
resolving but also multiple metastatic
lesions in some cases and we're hoping
this could affect cancer survival by
affecting many different metastases okay
answer at the beginning another yes
question is to what extent does bacteria
in the body affect methylation it's a
great question I believe it does we have
a little bit of data that it does but
it's completely it's almost completely
unknown right now but I I think that ten
years from now we will have discovered
that the bacteria in our body are
essential for maintaining the epigenomic
health of the cells that are exposed to
them such as our GI tract is there a
question in the balcony is it just for
maternal care or maternal or any
caregivers right so our rats are all
focused on maternal care because the
fathers don't participate in care in any
way shape or form among the row but when
you have a species where the father's do
you participate in the care they can
have similar epigenetic effects on
offspring and there's more and more
research being done on on species in
which there's exclusive paternal care or
caregiving by other individuals and they
have they have very similar effects so
it's really about your experience as an
individual with whoever is providing the
care rather than directed by some
specific individual whether it's mother
father or Francis can't even substitute
they use a paintbrush and actually get
that instead of looking yeah instead of
licking I don't recommend
you can also you can also have other
mothers raised yeah the apps have
exactly this caregivers would have the
same effect as the others even if they
are not mother's exact I wonder how many
babies do not are gonna be tickled by
paintbrush yes again repeat the question
so that we got have you done expression
or race with with mice the guty mice to
see whether or not you know some
nutritional exposure whatever target the
target alert expression arrays with that
their their small plates or whatever
that look at the expression of a whole
bunch of genes at one time and so you
could look then to determine whether or
not a certain exposure altered the
expression of a bunch of different genes
in which what they are we have that
simple answer that we have not done that
but it could be done we've only looked
at two genes in the GU t Mouse and both
of those genes we looked at were changed
in the same way but that doesn't mean
that there wouldn't be other genes that
were that would be reduced or whatever
but we just have not looked so one more
question obviously what that tells us
for those of us that didn't understand
that question or that answer or that
answer is I did get a sense of the
you're just at the beginning we're at
that you have a lot of stuff to do all
right
that's it one more I see a hand up there
don't have any use to be a human holding
your hand up yes between culture and
epigenomics a great last question for
each of our each of our panelists randy
any epigenomics and culture we can come
back to you let me think about all right
Frances so culture is another exciting
route through which you can have a
transmission of traits over generations
or characteristics of the general
population
so it is likely you know often
geneticists will referred to that as a
kind of a soft way of transmitting
traits and certainly it's likely going
to recruit epigenetic changes within
whole populations to to foster changes
across generation so I think culture
epigenetics parental effects and
genetics really form kind of a
collective of ways to transmit traits
across generations and culture affects
what we eat did affect how we eat it
affects what we drink and ultimately
these things on the long run affects how
our epigenome ages and therefore risk
for age-related diseases one of the most
remarkable observations in cancer
research is if you take migrants people
who move from one country to the other
within one generation they adopt the
cancer risk of the country they move to
so many people for example at very low
cone cancer rates in the past when they
move to the US they have the same cone
cancer rates as the US and that's party
culture and so it is very important and
it's partly through the epigenome Randy
my only addition to that is really I
mean that was a wonderful answer what is
that you know from our original study
what we showed it is very relatively
subtle changes in nutrition very early
in development can have profound effects
on ultimately disease susceptibility
through altering of the epigenome so to
the degree that culture is altering the
even the food that you're taking in etc
you can see very clearly if we have the
same phenomena occurring in humans how
culture could have a dramatic effect
the epigenome and also diseases whole
new world to study out there great last
question so let's give them a big round
of applause
[Applause]
you